[Music]  Amy Schumer packs on the PDA with chef  Chris Fischer sneaky pose was to him the  36 year old actress took to Instagram to  share this sexy snap kissing her rumored  boyfriend on Saturday the pair has been  linked since November and the smooch  during Ellen DeGeneres's star-studded  60th birthday bash in Los Angeles seems  to confirm the relationship is on Kim  Kardashian Kanye West Olivia Munn and  more stars partied alongside Amy and her  new man sharing the fun and celebrations  to social media Meghan Trainor posted  this pic with the birthday girl saying  the bash was quote the coolest night of  her entire life if Iowa zoo had won  [Music]